Brent power called and dr. darling are  back this time with their dues Cyber  Command Oh kids Roxanne and Slater play  is the Ravia swing huge the side of Mars  and defy gravity on your ultimate dragon  slayer supervised protect America with  Freda flips and ride on the ridiculous  roller coaster of righteousness grapple  and spin all over the planet use guns to  shoot cyborg communist aliens and giant  ancient dragon ball  base is the place and the action is in  your face right through noobs boobs and  multiple dimension into the future come  fight Vietnam War for  together forever today trials of the  blood dragon side effects may include  folia an extreme patriotic views  you